hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we are talking about pair
programming and why you need to start
doing it yesterday yeah yeah you're
you're late i'll first like to thank
postscreen for sponsoring this video
co-screen is amazing collaboration and
screen sharing tool and i know a lot of
people kind of cringe at the thought of
pair programming but code screen really
makes it this fun enjoyable experience
that you can't wait to have and so
before we talk more about that first
let's go into
what is pair programming so pair
programming you know the name itself is
quite self-explanatory
it is programming in a pair or in some
type of group ideally you team up with
one other person and you all decide who
will be the driver who will be the
navigator the driver is the person who
really actually types and codes things
out while the navigator kind of guides
that driver if you're thinking about a
car the driver is you know the person
behind the wheel but the navigator is
the person with the map making sure
we're going the right place and we're
not missing anything i didn't miss that
turn over there that's really the
dynamics of pair programming if you are
less skilled i always recommend kind of
counter intuitively to be the driver
yeah to be the person coding because
that way let's say you are practicing
javascript for the first time and you
are kind of still iffy on if statements
and so you want to
have that practice actually coding
things out and that way the navigator
can be the person guiding you and if
they're the person more skilled then
their skill sets are heightened by
having to now explain things to you and
so i feel doing it this way honestly
gives you the best results for both
people because think about it if you are
the person more skilled and you're the
driver
now the second person kind of is just
sitting there because the driver knows
all there is to know well quon quote
there really is never all there is no
anyway so the driver knows all this much
and they're coating things out totally
forgetting that you're even in the
passenger seat trying to make sure that
they're going the right way but you know
they're going 90 miles an hour on the
highway so you can't even figure out on
the map where you're supposed to be and
so i feel like doing it the opposite way
having the person less skilled or less
comfortable with what you're currently
working on being the driver really just
benefits everybody all around and there
are just so many benefits when it comes
to pair programming one knowledge
sharing i've talked about peer
programming a bit in the past saying how
it's a great way to
figure out different solutions even for
problems and concepts that you think you
have down now you see a different way
you could have coded out this if
statement you see that you can actually
use a ternary operator like what i
didn't know this is the thing well now
because you pair programmed this person
said oh actually we can just use this
with the one liner ternary and it's like
oh wow i learned something new it's also
great for getting through roadblocks
much
quicker because yeah now you have two
eyes on one project even if the other
person doesn't even know how to solve a
certain problem just by having these two
heads two sets of eyes looking at
something working something out together
oh my goodness it can speed up the
development process like crazy and
another reason to really take pair
programming seriously and i'm speaking
to y'all who are trying to get into this
field for self teaching or are going
through coding boot camp y'all you will
be pair programming on the job
yes take it from me i just started my
job about a month ago and i have already
had multiple pair programming sessions
and so it is so important to already
feel comfortable with the act itself
when i used it in my job it was for a
different developer guiding me through
this project i was put on because it's
so hard when
you i i'm grateful i'm very grateful to
be in this field and to be where i am
but y'all it is
difficult
entering a new team
and you are now on projects that have
been there been there long before you
even were a thought and so now you have
to figure out okay what is this code
doing what are the functions being used
what is the standard of coding it's a
lot rather than going through a coding
bootcamp for self-teaching you kind of
are building these projects from ground
zero you know what i mean you're
building these apps building these
projects from ground to zero and so you
are there throughout the entire process
but when you're on a team and you get on
a team for the first time you are
starting from the top of the mountain
and you don't know how you got that you
just got dropped to the top and i was
like okay climb and so it gets difficult
and so that's where pair programming at
work really takes place for me at least
is when it's like okay here is how we
are setting up the stage for what you're
going to be working on let's pair
program for the next hour so you get
comfortable with our systems with this
new language you're learning and with
simply how we code that's repair
programming comes in getting you more
comfortable with coding on this team and
so that's why i had done it actually
yesterday and about two weeks ago and so
it's important that you already feel
comfortable doing it you want to have
that practice of turning what another
person is saying to you into code and
being comfortable with that back and
forth and then also flipping it of
testing your own knowledge by being the
navigator to someone else because y'all
i'm sure we all know one of the best
ways to learn is to teach it is to teach
and it's a great way to see where you're
at with something do you really
understand it because if you don't
really understand it you'll see it when
you try to explain it to another person
and so it's a great way to just increase
your knowledge so so much and so let's
go into tools so the very first tool i'm
going to be talking about and the one
i'm most excited to talk about is coast
green coast korea is a collaborative
screen sharing and video chat tool it's
amazing for pair programming and also
group programming sessions because you
all can not only share your screen
that's like not even the fun part not
only share your screen but now that this
person has shared their screen you can
grab onto their screen you can type into
their screen if somebody else pulls up a
browser and shares that browser now i
can go into the browser and be like
actually let's go to github instead and
type that in and it's on their browser
but here i am manipulating it and so
that's why it's so amazing for pair
programming because you have vs code up
you have your driver navigator so your
driver is coding things out you're the
navigator you're in charge of scoping
out the scene making sure all's good
other typos are their broken statements
and if you spot those let's say you spot
a typo like nothing crazy that you
really need to alert your driver about
so you just go in and fix the typo for
them seamlessly they may not even see it
they may not even realize you did it and
what's amazing is your system does not
feel slow at all while it's running you
don't feel any type of lag and
everything is still crystal clear and
sharp and it is there's no difference
it's as if they're there with you coding
this problem out helping you learn and
develop your skill sets and honestly
it's just a very fun tool to use i've
used it and i love it i now i kind of
just find any excuse to use it like okay
well i'm about to watch netflix does
someone want to hop on code screen with
me and
like now i just use it for everything
it's just so fun and it takes that angst
away from video calls and pair
programming because i think all of us
with 2020 and now 2021 and who knows how
many more 20 20 somethings we are
feeling that zoom fatigue i'm not going
to speak for you but me i am feeling
that zoom fatigue i'm like okay y'all i
am in a video chat it seems like every
other 30 minutes like i can't do this
anymore like can we just not and so this
is great because it's not focused on the
video chat part of things really there's
just the little bubbles on the side of
okay this person is here they are active
in the session and so it just makes that
work session that much more enjoyable
along with post screens that's tool
number one there are also other tools
such as vs code live share fies go live
share is great because you can access it
via vs code you just download the
extension and there you go and so it's
also great for pair programming because
you get to collaborate with one another
being able to see the exact screen and
files and terminals that people are
working with but the only thing with vs
code is you still need to have some kind
of other video session up like zoom or
microsoft teams or any of the sorts you
still need that video tool up to
seamlessly talk and see and chat with
one another they do have a chat tool but
it's not fun
having to stop your code to then go into
the chat and then see the response from
the chat and then go back to your code
i'm a person who i'm over here talking
it out and coding simultaneously so i
don't really like that break in my
operational flow and lastly you can do
the simple zoom session you can do just
the zoom session you share your screen
and you have that driver navigator
relationship of okay this person is
going to be coding it out the other
person is going to be talking to them
the only thing is if you want to switch
at any point who's the driver who's the
navigator or let's say you see a typo
that the other person doesn't see
kind of all operations need to seize and
you have to address those things and so
let's say you see a typo then it's like
yo
tom tom can you hear me am i oh shoot
i'm muted tom you have a typo and then
they have to go back up into their typo
fix it and then continue and so it's
less of a seamless
experience and if you ever want to
switch who's the driver and who's the
navigator that also sees this operation
for a second because now the original
driver needs to stop sharing their
screen the new driver needs to start
sharing their screen and it's a more
manual switch that needs to happen you
actually have to get out of the car
switch seats and sit down but it too can
get the job done and so that's really
why i love code screen the first time i
used it it took no time at all it took
no
figuring out and that's another thing
with vs code it does take some figuring
out there are multiple setup steps that
you need to really figure out before you
can really dive in but this once you get
it installed you get into the session
and
boom you're off to the races like y'all
i really love this tool i really love
this tool like i said i use any excuse
to start using and it's the first time
you use it you'll see you'll get very
impressed you'll be like oh wow i can
just i can just go into here and just
copy and paste something that's on your
screen and copy it onto my screen or fix
your typo and you don't even see any
difference in again lag time or any
operational difficulties it's it's a
great experience and what's great is you
can use code screen for free there is a
bit of a limitation on how many sessions
you can have per month is about 10
sessions a month for the free plan
however if you comment down below i will
be choosing three people to get a
lifetime membership with co-screen so
now that cap on sessions you can do per
month it is gone and so make sure you
leave a comment below and lastly i'm
going to talk about where to get a pair
programming partner this is something i
find to be very important especially if
you are self teaching or going to
according boot camp and in general not
in an institution like a college or
something where you have you know your
dorm mates and your classmates and all
of this just available to you if you are
going through coding boot camp you are
actually in a pretty good place i do
highly recommend just hitting up the
chat and saying yo who has one hour i
would love to pair programs this is
something that i did i went to flat art
school for anyone who doesn't know but i
went to planner school last year and i
would do this and other people would do
this too of okay who wants to pay a
program for the next 30 minutes i am
working on this project i'd love to pair
program now where it gets tricky is if
you are self-teaching if you are
self-teaching join some type of group
like a facebook group a slack channel a
linkedin group join some type of group
that's focused on programming especially
programming either as a beginner or
self-teaching and so join something that
speaks to you and be active on those
channels make relationships and say hey
i would love to have a pair programming
session with somebody you don't need to
have a whole project set up you can even
just do a leak code session with someone
like i'm going to be going over five
problems on late code i would love to
pair program with someone as we solve
these problems together so go past just
using your ide to problem solve because
being a software engineer is just so
much more than that it's about true
meaningful collaboration and so that's
what you should practice while on your
journey to become such and so i love
code screen because it does such an
amazing job at helping you do that i
understand that pair programming can
sometimes be this thing of like oh
oh no and there can be so much
hesitation so
little buy-in especially with beginners
you feel like you're not there yet or
you just are
you just feel asked about it either
because you feel like it's too advanced
for you or you're afraid of having
someone watch your code because you're
like what if they say i'm not good
enough or what if they show me all these
problems and all of these things y'all
seriously if for no other reason do it
because on the job it is going to be
something that you want to feel
comfortable with already so make sure
you
be a download of that knowledge sharing
and just become a better developer in
general so thank you all so much for
watching don't forget to leave that
comment below and i'll talk to you later
bye